the death toll continues to rise to the
fatal gas line explosion in Mexico
authorities say that the pipeline had
been ruptured by suspected oil thieves
people who were lighting cigarettes they
were dancing they were throwing gasoline
on top of each other completely
intoxicated by the fumes they took their
fill the soldiers sent to guard the
pipeline looked on seemingly powerless
then this happened
[Applause]
and essentially with a matter of seconds
the whole thing ignited
people were running from the blast like
human torches now there's a complete
chaos
was important a most important thing now
is to look after the injured to save
lives that is the most important thing
the fight against the illegal theft of
fuel will be strengthened the state
losses in the region of 3 billion US
dollars a year and over 95% of the water
Nonna's Thomas clandestinos which our
legal extractions are are done by big
cartels
my name is matthew Bremner I'm a
Scottish writer and I wrote the story
about Mexico's biggest pipeline
explosion
within the first sort of 24 hours people
said there were 20 people dead and 71
people injured obviously those numbers
like rocketed up but the final death
toll as it were is 134 now
[Music]
in the field where the area great
irrigation trench was were the pipeline
runs framed by an old tree which was
scorched in the blast there is no shrine
almost every day
relatives of the victims go there they
set on little plastic benches or wooden
crates they stare at me at the the
crosses often crying sometimes in some
sort of trance and they spend hours
there it's the same always in society
the the people who are at the bottom of
the tree the people that were there
looking to take advantage of an
opportunity they're the people that
always suffer
[Music]
the scale of all theft in Mexico is
enormous the state loses three billion
US dollars a year watch it Kaleo which
is the illegal siphoning on tapping of
fuel which has been happening in Mexico
now for about 25 years perhaps longer
what was a very informal industry and
has now become something which is far
more organized a lot of the big Mexican
cartels are now branching into the scale
of all theft half of their business is
now
focused on people fuel tapping
it's a lot less risky essentially to get
involved in their legal field rate
because you don't need to transport
drugs across borders you don't need to
pay off different types of police in
different countries
there are corruption inside the big
petrol giant in this case petróleos
mexicanos Pemex is rampant and so it's
quite easy to to pay off workers inside
to find out when the oil is is flowing
through certain pipelines and to rob it
and then sell it domestically on the
black market
Pemex is one of the biggest oil
companies in the world for a long time
it was considered a cash cow for the
mixen economy it it kept it kept Mexico
afloat in many ways and people always
refer to as you know the most important
institution and that the country had
the government recently released figures
that
around 80% of the Thomas clandestinos
and the few robberies that take place in
Mexico are organized in some way by
insiders in Pemex
what would normally happen is that they
would have a link inside demyx who would
tell them through which pipeline a
certain it could be gasoline it could be
gas it could be anything he's running
and what time and what the pressure is
they would then go down to the specific
pipeline normally at nighttime normally
the pipes are about between one to two
meters below the ground they would dig
to get to the pipeline and it would
perforate it with a high-powered drill
then a professional solderer would come
in and he would solder a tap to the pipe
they know exactly what they're doing
when they need to do it and the risks
that that entails so they're
professionals
one of the watch ecole arrows in the
Hidalgo area told me that in one night
the organization that he worked for can
make up to 90 thousand pesos if you take
that into account that an average wage
at least in that area from what people
were telling me is about 1,500 pesos a
week then you know we're talking serious
money here
around midday there was a rumor that was
spread that a pipeline had been
perforated and the people were illegally
siphoning gasoline from one of the based
pipelines in Mexico
around 2:30 in the afternoon a patrol of
25 officers from the military arrived
so this this was quite an unusual
occurrence simply because normally few
robberies would take place at night
and women and children were turning up
in in in vans and cars on foot and on
bicycles and motorbikes and coming to
the area in huge numbers
within the next two to three hours what
may have been 80 people soon was six
times that
felt like they were almost celebrating
in some sort of way if it like a water
party heard people say generally they
were just local townspeople who were
taking advantage of the situation
to get refuel
one thing that's very important here is
the the fuel that was running through
this particular pipeline was very high
octane which meant that it released lots
of very very very flammable gases
because the day itself was relatively
hot these gases were were sort of
floating above the crowd it hadn't yet
got to the stage where it was it was low
enough to be ignited so around six
o'clock when it began to get darker and
the temperature dropped those gases also
dropped and so they sort of began to
smother the crowd
now the interesting thing is that the
fire created inside of a cigarette butt
is not hot enough to ignite petrol but
what is hot enough is static electricity
and what would have probably happened is
that a static shock would have come from
somewhere whether two hands that were
being shaken or the friction grades
being two people were rubbing up against
each other and that would have created a
static shock which would have been hot
enough to ignite these gases which had
now sunk down and essentially within a
matter of seconds the whole thing
ignited
[Applause]
and as the thicken of the ignition of
the of the fire settles down somewhat
then you see the people running from the
blast and this is perhaps the most
impactful moment because the people
they're running from the blast are in
flames some of them trip over some of
them run towards the road some of them
are rolling on the ground some of them
are crying for for water that
[Music]
the local paramedics came in first from
the surrounding villages and when they
go to the the field they they saw
people's arriving and on the on the
floor in agony they saw charred bodies
that were you know completely
incinerated you know sort of falling
falling apart people that were in sort
of their last moments of agony but
burned into that position what they saw
was the most horrific thing that you
possibly see I could imagine
[Music]
the Mexican government has declared war
on what you call a Oh are they winning
it I think it's far too early to say
will they win it
well if the drug war is anything to go
by then probably not
[Music]
you